former u.s surgeon general dr jerome
adams joins us now to talk about all
this dr adams good morning
good morning so florida's governor says
the state could withhold the salaries of
school officials who defies order to ban
mask mandates as a physician as a father
what's your reaction to that
well as a physician as a public health
expert it is deeply troubling that it
seems we're letting politics get in the
way
of protecting our our youth as a father
i quite frankly think it's
unconscionable i really do i think you
can't tie the hand to school and public
health officials
based on
what you perceive to be the the reality
when your public health officials are
telling you they need these tools
and you've said recently that this
pandemic is spiraling out of control
again uh what do you think the next few
weeks the next few months are going to
look like
well we're going to see more spread
unfortunately and today i'm touring
oklahoma university health center we're
hearing that our nurses are doctors they
are quite simply overwhelmed we're going
to see increasing hospitalizations
fortunately with higher vaccination
rates we're not going to see as many
deaths as we as we could otherwise see
but it's going to be a really tough next
couple of weeks and parents if your kids
are over 12 please talk to your doctor
or health provider and get your
questions answered so you can get them
vaccinated you can consider wearing a kn
95 or 95 n95 mask because they're
available now and keep an eye on the
numbers in your areas the coded numbers
so that you can make an informed
decision even if the politicians out
there are telling you that they won't
let it be mandated we've talked a lot
about the impact of covet on minority
communities too and i want to turn now
to a new report which shows an alarming
racial divide when it comes to medical
care finding that minority patients are
underrepresented for elective care at
roughly four out of five u.s hospitals
and that leads to worse health outcomes
for people of color this may not be a
surprise to people but there are the
numbers to back it up what can we make
out of this
well number one if you're a leader of
one of these top institutions you should
be embarrassed you should be ashamed
because what u.s news and world report
is telling us is these aren't the top
health care institutions for americans
they're the top-end health care
institutions for white americans four
out of five hospitals in this country
are serving lower than their demographic
share of black and brown people
they're not having equitable access to
cancer surgeries to heart surgeries to
orthopedic surgery they could get them
back out walking and living life again
and uh kudos to u.s news and world
report for calling it out but next year
they need to incorporate it into the
overall rankings and lift up places like
oklahoma university health places like
eskenazi health where i work in
indianapolis who actually serve
populations that represent
that represent the surrounding
demographics
go ahead well i was going to say dr
adams one way to close this gap is is on
the hospital side but also on the
patient side another finding from the
study was that even black residents who
have insurance are less likely to get
preventative care and then show up with
a big issue how do you address that
well we know that there is a trust gap
and part of that trust gap comes from
your workforce we need to make sure at
these big institutions we're recruiting
doctors and nurses and other staff that
look like the surrounding community they
need to step out and get into the
community i've been to some of these top
institutions hopkins cleveland clinic
ucla and i've challenged them i said how
come you'll send people around the world
to give care but the people on your
campus are scared to go two blocks off
of the hospital campus and you aren't
investing in the surrounding communities
we need to build that trust people need
to know that you care before they care
what you know and these institutions
need to show those surrounding
communities they care so that they'll
feel comfortable coming there you know
dr adams a lot of people have talked
about the distrust that some minorities
feel when it comes to the healthcare
system but when you read studies that
show typically people of color receive
care at lower quality hospitals um and
that contributes to some of the outcomes
that we're talking about that tony
mentioned maybe the mistrust is is not
all that surprising if the care is lower
quality is the study fine right exactly
that was my question dr adams i mean is
there is there at least a correlation
between that
there is a correlation but here's what
you need to understand
a lot of times these big institutions
they get big donations they take care of
more people who have commercial paying
because they're put on these u.s news
and world report top rankings and the
hospitals out there that are taking care
of the black and brown people they're
getting less funding they're less able
to recruit staff they have worse staff
to patient ratios and it ends up being a
cycle a self-perpetuating cycle so we
need to invest in these hospitals that
are taking care of black and brown
people and we need to challenge these
hospitals that aren't to do better
dr jerome adams thank you very very much
as always we appreciate it
thank you get vaccinated vaccines.gov
good advice thank you doctor